okay I'm considering leaving social
media forever period like just getting
off of social media altogether which is
sort of a difficult thing to do if you
host a show like this one that relies so
much on social media and on being in
touch with people on social media and
using social media to spread the content
that we make and I know that there are
some people in the audience who will
sort of react to this by saying why on
earth would you leave social media but
based on some of the emails I receive
and that's a key word emails I know that
there are lots of people in the audience
who will immediately understand why I'm
thinking of leaving social media
altogether and I could go into sort of
like a long sophisticated explanation of
why but I I don't think I really need to
social media is almost exclusively toxic
as a venue in which people exist and
interact and look at stuff and I'm gonna
kind of build the case up for you one
step at a time
first is the kind of like general
perspective later I'll talk about how it
applies to me as the host of a political
show but Jonathan height for example has
written extensively about the extremely
negative effect of just normal social
media usage on preteens and on high
schoolers at a psychological level and
even for adults the data is more and
more prevalent and overwhelming as far
as this goes which is that spending time
on social media scrolling through your
Facebook feed Twitter feed
it's just bad for our health it's bad
for our psychological health and our
physical health and there's on the one
hand the kind of addictive nature which
is similar to a slot machine just like
you can go back to the slot machine and
pull the lever one more time and maybe
you get something good you can always
scroll down a little bit more down your
Twitter or Facebook feed and you might
get something good and this is this goes
back to operant conditioning this is a
variable reward schedule that applies to
slot machines and it applies to social
media it sort of feels like high school
psychology class this is one of the
things that make social media addictive
and never satisfying because you can
always scroll a little more and maybe
see something even
better or more interesting than the last
thing so that's sort of layer one beyond
that we know that when people scroll
social media you're immediately sort of
automatically starting to compare
yourself with what you see comparing
your life with what's there and when you
compare your life in total with the
curated carefully selected moments and
stories and pictures that other people
are choosing to share it's an impossible
standard and even if we understand this
sort of intellectually as I think most
of us do on a subconscious level it
makes social media really bad for us and
it's not that I spend much time on
social media beyond what's necessary for
the show but there's also the kind of
time element of it if you add up all the
little bits of time that are spent on
Twitter and Facebook and Instagram
looking at a comment here checking out a
comment there it starts to add up and it
gets to what I consider to be sort of
the second layer of the problem if you
haven't read - of Cal Newports books
about this you should immediately read
them Cal Newport wrote the book deep
work years ago and it's about the lack
of what he calls deep work in modern
society people's jobs are increasingly
answering emails administrative tasks
all of what I would call shallow work
that's not actually central to what we
do that is valuable in my case like the
real value the deep work that I'm trying
to do is research and prepare stories
for the show to make the content of the
show as good as possible and the best
way to do this is total concentration no
email checking no social media I want to
be doing more of that more of that deep
work so it seems kind of natural to
eliminate as many of those shallow
behaviors from my day that aren't
totally necessary and social media is
one of them and then Cal Newport also
wrote another book more recently called
digital minimalism which I'll interview
him about in a couple of weeks which
goes beyond just the crisis of the lack
of deep work but it's more about the
damaging effect of most people's social
media use and the payoff is pretty
damn clear to me if I spend an hour
deeply learning about economic theory
that will actually pay dividends for the
show by virtue of me being more informed
for years to come
whereas if I spend that hour scrolling
Twitter and Facebook I might find
another topic or two to discuss on the
show maybe but it's not gonna provide
anything that really improves the show
over the long term so without even
getting specifically to what's going on
with my social media yet which I will
the need for doing deep work the waste
of time that most social media use
represents there's a really solid case
for at least drastically minimizing
social media use to specific moments in
the day which has been my strategy so
far okay so the way I have been sort of
managing this is that I have in my
schedule
as far as work goes in the morning
sometime after I finish up preparing the
day's show I'll check all social
networks I'll respond to what I want to
respond to
I'll make notes about things that I want
to follow up on if there are guest
suggestions people sent me your story
suggestions
alright back to personal messages and
then that's it and then late in the
afternoon I'll do another check but the
truth is I have the social apps on my
phone and it's very easy if I'm on the
subway or whatever to just check in on
stuff more often than I'm kind of
consciously trying to so that is all for
everybody that has nothing to do with my
sort of particular situation but then we
get to my social media feed and it's
toxic I mean that's it as many of you
know we get two to three thousand
YouTube comments per day at this point
and I've made it clear that I look at
barely any I mean it's a total cesspool
there's very little benefit other than
I'll look at what videos did well which
videos were heavily liked which videos
were heavily disliked but that's
basically it and unfortunately my
Twitter feed my Facebook feed it is
gotten absolutely horrible and this is
kind of like a curse of success in a
sense the show is now big enough that
any time I go to Twitter there are
dozens if not
of messages just insults attacks
insulting the show some of its from the
right what really sort of is pushing me
towards maybe abandoning social media
all together is the infighting from the
left people on the left saying this
person is not actually left enough or
that person is too far left or this
person is parroting right wing talking
points and obviously in small doses all
of this stuff is fine but the
signal-to-noise ratio has gotten way way
too low in most of these cases and I had
a conversation with with Sam cedar about
this in Vegas a couple of weeks ago and
I said I'm thinking about it minimum
getting off Twitter if not all social
media and he said just mute people so
that you don't see them which is fine
but I have thousands of people muted on
Twitter and I don't really know that I
need to be on these platforms it seems
that there's a lot to gain from
screening them out as an example like do
I need to know that some guy with a
YouTube channel did a 15 minute video
attacking me or will I be basically fine
and the show will be just as good if I
focus on my work rather than looking at
who's doing Twitter posts about me and
the only hesitation I have is that part
of the success of the show is thanks to
social media right social media has been
a very important tool for spreading
awareness and the content of the David
Pakman show so it's weird for me to say
I'm completely getting off of it so I
need to think about it a little bit and
in mid-may I'm going to be interviewing
Cal Newport and this is one of the
things I want to talk to him about which
is does he think I'd be able to get off
of social media given that this is
although it's a radio and television
show it's also significantly an online
show or do I kind of need to grin and
bear it in some sense because of the
importance of social media to the show
maybe I could start looking at just like
verified people's posts on Twitter but
that's problematic because most of our
audience isn't verified on Twitter so
maybe the answer is I just cut it and I
say you know what if you want to get in
touch with me email me actually take the
time to send
me an email I don't know what the answer
is but I'm curious what people think
if you've adopted a sort of digital
minimalism concept into your life I want
to hear about it and one of the really
important things that I want to not
ignore is that whenever people read
about digital minimalism and these types
of issues when people like Cal Newport
write about them the reaction is often a
reflexive that might work for other
people but it wouldn't work for me I
need to be on these platforms because if
X Y Z reason and what I am open to is
the idea that that may just not be the
case like maybe it's not actually that
central to what we're doing so let me
know what you think I want to hear about
your social media use tell me if I'm
completely off on this let me know via
email I would say actually take the time
to write to me and I will eventually I
guess make some kind of decision and let
you know where I land today's show was
made possible in part by better help.com
slash Pakman better help is a service
that gives you unlimited remote access
to your own fully licensed therapist by
way of phone video and text it's less
expensive than physically going to see a
therapist in an office and you don't
need to have insurance to use better
help and they stand behind what they do
better help has a no-questions-asked
full money-back guarantee if you're not
satisfied with your experience all of
better helps counselors are thoroughly
vetted for accreditation and experience
it's all spelled out in their Terms of
Service
better help requires all of its
counselors to be fully trained and
licensed and they must have at least 3
years and 2,000 hours of counseling
experience so you know that your
counselor is qualified to help you but
if you don't think your counselor is the
right fit for you better help makes it
easy to switch to a new one if you've
been thinking about getting involved
with a therapist you should really check
out better help just click the link
underneath this video